these people are in line to vote early
in Philadelphia
nothing unusual about that except these
voters had already voted they cast their
ballots by mail but they were missing
one thing an accurate handwritten date
the lawsuit that got these ballots
thrown out was filed by the Republican
National Committee it's part of a larger
effort led by allies of former president
Donald Trump many of whom ran for
election in the 2022 midterms in the
news you'll often hear this group
referred to as election deniers and
while it's true they do still deny that
Joe Biden won in 2020. what they can do
is just as important as what they say in
2020 nearly three quarters of U.S voters
cast their ballots early or by mail
but these politicians want to limit and
even get rid of these practices
altogether this plan is what motivated
thousands of volunteers across the
country ahead of the 2022 midterms they
didn't just fight election deniers in a
lot of places they beat them and how
they did it could be the key to
protecting free fair and open elections
in the U.S for years to come
let's take another look at those mail-in
ballots in Philadelphia on Monday I got
like 15 calls and like 10 text messages
from a variety of like volunteers and
like political people about my ballot
the day before the election I got a text
from a friend like thousands of other
voters in Pennsylvania Kristen and Zoe
had already verified their identities by
providing a Pennsylvania issued ID
number when they applied for their
mail-in balance
their ballots had been postmarked and
stamped by the Philadelphia Board of
Elections on the day they were received
and yet these lists came out that list
people who would sit in a mail-in ballot
that was invalid for some reason your
name showed up I was like disappointed
myself for a second I'm like how did I
date this incorrectly like I really
thought I was following all the you know
the rules and what the guidelines are to
have how to fill it out Pennsylvania has
had mail-in voting since 2019 and in
every election since then multiple
judges have ruled that missing date
should not mean a ballot gets thrown out
but just weeks before the last day to
vote in 2022 a group of Republican
politicians sued to try to get a
different ruling and it worked the
candidate at the top of the ticket for
Republicans gubernatorial Canada Doug
mastriano was like noted election denier
I am the elections director for the
Mid-Atlantic region For the Working
Families party I'm a proud resident of
Philadelphia Pennsylvania the greatest
city in the world we knew that there was
a risk that people would use mail-in
voting specifically as a way of
attacking the legitimacy of the
elections overall we ended up with over
1300 unique volunteers who are calling
voters to help them cure ballots and
make sure their voices were heard Doug
mastriano lost his bid for governor and
and Democrats now control the
Pennsylvania state house
if enough State reps want to change that
rule about the handwritten dates on the
outside of envelopes they can
like mastriano in Pennsylvania one of
the candidates for Governor in Michigan
Tudor Dixon had also cast doubt on the
2020 election results more than half the
state's 5.5 million votes in 2020 were
cast by mail and even though Republicans
in the state senate authored a report
that found no evidence of widespread or
systemic fraud that didn't stop Tudor
Dixon from tweeting about stolen
elections and it didn't stop the
republican-led state legislature from
introducing 39 bills to dramatically
limit mail-in and early voting there are
many many reasons why people would want
to vote by absentee ballot but for some
reason some politicians want to make it
harder Kim's organization voters not
politicians recruited more than 300
volunteers and knocked down over a
hundred thousand doors I remember on
Election Day I woke up at about six
o'clock in the morning I went all up and
down my street I really want to talk to
you today about prop 2 is going to give
us all the constitutional rights about
without harassment or interference
included by our own legislators it's
going to give us all nine days of true
early in-person voting if you rode
through Detroit you will see this area
especially where I live it was covered
with prop 2 PSI Yes on Prop 2. you're
going to be able to opt in to you know a
system where you can request your bill
at once and then get it for every future
election it was worth it you know in the
end it paid off prop 2 passed in
Michigan by a large margin and Tudor
Dixon lost but even if she hadn't
because of prop 2 Michigan's
Constitution now contains an explicit
promise to the state citizens that their
votes will be counted I'm passionate
about voting rights I know what my
ancestors went through so I'm here to
fight for democracy and uh I'll be here
until I guess I leave this earth
the issue of voting free from
interference was front and center in
Arizona too I have been so pleased to
hear of all you Vigilantes out there
that want to camp out at these drop
boxes right
Carrie Lake one of the candidates for
Arizona governor tweeted her support for
this surveillance project smile you
might be on camera so we're gonna have
people parked out there watching you and
they're going to follow you to your car
and get your license plate it's gonna
happen she was right it did happen armed
Vigilantes dressed in tactical gear guys
and body armor carrying guns and taking
your picture pole stalkers people who've
been staking out ballot drop boxes under
the guise of preventing widespread voter
fraud people spoke up they dropped off
their ballots and then they filed
complaints with the Secretary of State
there's a group of people hanging out
near the ballot Dropbox filming and
photographing my wife and I as we
approach the Dropbox and accusing us of
being a mule
camo Cloud people taking pictures of me
and my license plate as I dropped our
mail-in ballots in the Box a
pro-democracy group filed a lawsuit and
the judge issued a temporary restraining
order the people voted and Kerry Lake
lost by a very small margin the ballot
drop boxes she threatened to remove the
early voting she threatened to cut off
they're both safe
for now
the US doesn't have one big election it
has over 3 000 small elections run
mostly by Volunteers in high school gyms
and libraries and community centers and
that can make it easy for some
politicians to cast doubt on their
efficacy out of self-interest
but it also means that anyone who cares
about making them actually work can go
from a bystander to an active
participant in the fight to keep
democracy alive and well anyone can go
from standing in line to standing behind
the table
thank you guys so much for watching one
of the things we're trying to do on this
channel is really just be like your
One-Stop shop for context for the news
like if something is happening you're
seeing lots of headlines about it and
you want to dig deeper you want to know
more like that's what we're here for one
of the ways we're actually trying to do
this is by answering your questions you
can send us a question and we will dig
in and try to find some answers for you
like a couple weeks ago Kim and I made a
video about the ethics of zoos that came
from an amazing question from one of our
subscribers girls a few months back Joss
made an Incredible video about the
history of unions and why they didn't
gain more of a foothold in the service
industry in the U.S these are the kinds
of questions that we love digging into
stuff that comes from your brain like
you guys are smart and we want to work
with you so check out the form it's
linked in the description of this video
fill it out ask us a question and we'll
get some answers thanks for watching